for the EU the dairy market is extremely
important that you is world's leading
exporter of many dairy products like
milk butter or cheese every year 160
million tons of milk is produced 15% of
EU egra cultural output milk is produced
in every EU Member State the main
producers are Germany France the United
Kingdom Poland the Netherlands and Italy
which together account for almost
seventy percent of the EU production
dairy sector is currently currently
experiencing a prolonged market
disturbance and this is mainly due to a
gap between demand and supply the price
is affected by this mismatch obviously
and in some Member States this has gone
even below the production costs and this
is the reason why farmers are in
distress in some of our member states
certainly the Baltic states are having a
difficult time in relation to the
continuation of the Russian ban EU milk
quota were introduced to eliminate
overproduction and fight the growing
imbalance between production costs and
low milk prices earlier this year you
terminated its milk quota system on the
one hand this is very good in the medium
and longer term on the other hand in the
short term it will require some
adjustment and will most likely be
linked to a certain price volatility